welcome back to the stronger by science
podcast my name is eric trexler i'm the
host of the show but
today i am going to be joined by a very
special temporary guest co-host his name
is greg knuckles greg how you doing
doing well how are you
i am doing great um obviously today is
valentine's day uh arguably the biggest
holiday in the united states
and my girlfriend hasn't posted yet
about it and more specifically about me
and how much she appreciates me and my
qualities but
the nice thing is it's only like 1 30.
so i think tonight she's probably
planning a really big post so i'm
looking forward to to definitely seeing
that
on social media um all right so before
we get into the podcast today uh
just a few reminders
if you'd like to support this show there
are many ways to do it so you could like
rate or subscribe
wherever you access the show
you could use our discount code at
bulksupplements.com the code is sbs pod
sbs
pod and that gets you a five percent
discount on your order and you could
also subscribe to the mass research
review which greg and i are co-authors
of along with dr mike zordos and dr
eric helms and then finally if you're in
the market for a high quality diet app
with really convenient tracking features
uh macro factor is the diet app that we
designed uh if you're not sure if it's
going to be right for you we do offer a
free trial so you can take it for a spin
and see if you like it uh okay road to
the stage greg how are things going uh
yeah things things are going reasonably
well i would say um
nothing really exciting to report i'm
targeting a relatively slow rate of
weight loss so weight has been
essentially flat for the past week which
is something that you should anticipate
from time to time
[Music]
but
so one of the things in lifting that i
like is kind of a
a mile post that things are going pretty
well
is when i have a really bad day in the
gym
uh
whatever weights that i can still hit
there
is kind of an indicator to me
that i'm definitely at least that strong
so you know if if i have a really bad
day in the gym training doesn't go well
but then i look back and say like oh you
know the numbers i hit today
are the numbers i get hit on a good day
six months ago then it's like you know
that that's still progress in a way um
you know it wasn't my best day but my
best or my worst day now is as good as
my best day not all that long ago
uh and so today when we're recording is
the day after the super bowl uh
had fun last night um ate a lot drank a
fair bit uh
i'm about as bloated as i ever get right
now um and i woke up at like 2 35 which
was
a number on the way down that i was very
excited to hit not all that long ago so
i'm viewing that through kind of
the same prison prism uh as i do
you know hitting numbers on a bad day in
the gym for lifting so
all things considered i view that a
positive indicator um
another thing that i'm very excited
about is the weather is finally getting
better uh it's
you know i i feel bad for
for all of our listeners in canada and
the northeast and
i think like probably northern europe as
well
where mid february is still cold time um
we have short winters here in the south
here in north carolina and mid-february
is is generally when things really start
warming up and like pretty consistently
getting into
the high 50s to low 70s again
um
yeah the weather is getting a lot better
it's gonna start becoming much more
convenient to get outside more take more
walks
so i'm i'm very much looking forward to
that just in a general sense but also as
it relates to road to the stage um it's
gonna be a lot easier to get more steps
in get more active
uh so yeah that's that's very nice how
is uh how's the road to athens
uh the road to athens is fine there's
nothing too exciting to report i did
want to mention i think it's really
important what you alluded to there the
idea of
finding different ways to
monitor your progress
so like you know when lifters start
getting to a really high level
you will find that sometimes you have to
remind them like if they're like hey i
can't just throw five pounds on the bar
you know five more pounds every time i
go to the gym you have to say well
you're doing the same load that you did
last time but your rpe is lower you know
kind of less conventional ways to look
at progress over time and the same thing
goes with weight tracking like
sometimes i have to remind my clients i
know that you're
you know focused on yesterday's weigh-in
but consider what your highs and your
lows used to be and now consider what
your highs and lows are today rather
than getting caught up on you know any
specific singular weigh-in so i think
that's really important to keep in mind
um but shifting to the road to athens
like i said nothing too exciting i've
been keeping the mileage per session
really low but i've been keeping the
frequency of my runs higher
and i've been doing a lot of extra stuff
that to me is really boring but i think
is necessary
i i've been having some
hip and lower abdominal issues when
running pretty painful stuff
unfortunately but i've been doing a lot
of stretching a lot of additional core
work and that's been helping a lot so
you know it's
nothing too exciting but
uh much in line with the uh
the road to enlightenment i've been
trying to focus on enjoying the process
rather than just focusing on
the metrics like just looking at mileage
week over week and running times i've
been trying to actually enjoy the
process of getting into running and
getting more proficient with it so
um within that context it's going pretty
good to be honest good
all right so in terms of the
uh
the heart of the episode here the
content i want to kick things off with a
very brief
uh research review so
this is going to be brief because it
basically just revisits some topics that
we've discussed on the show in the past
so we don't have to lay
the entire foundation and all the
groundwork for these topics but there
was a cool study recently that tied some
of these topics together in a way that i
think
makes the topics more understandable i i
think it fills a gap
and provides us with some additional
clarity where there used to be a little
bit of confusion uh from my perspective
so
the topics that we're talking about here
are basically um
they all fall under the umbrella of low
energy availability so
at various times in the podcast and in
stronger by science articles we've
alluded to topics like metabolic
adaptation
we've alluded to
uh energy compensation and what i mean
by that is you know if you add 100
calories of exercise to your daily
routine your total daily energy
expenditure is not likely to increase by
100 calories you will compensate in
other areas of energy expenditure so
rather than increasing your total daily
energy expenditure by 100 calories you
might only increase it by like
70 or 75 calories because of this
compensation in other areas so uh those
are the two topics that we talk about
but we also sometimes allude to things
like
uh relative energy deficiency in sport
so some of the more clinically oriented
symptoms that accompany low energy
availability so the general theme here
is that when we restrict energy
and we're doing a lot of exercise and
body weight is going down in most cases
what we see is a collection of
physiological responses
across many different aspects of our
physiology so
this particular study
was looking
at
compensation for the calories that we
spend on exercise but it was looking at
it specifically in the context of an
individual's energy balance
and so the idea was the study by the way
was by willis and colleagues the title
was physical activity and total daily
energy expenditure in older u.s adults
constrained versus additive models so
the constrained model we've talked about
that before uh one of the more uh
widely known researchers who talks about
it a lot is herman poncer he wrote the
book burn i think was the title yeah but
the idea with the constrained energy
model
is that
the compensation that we see
tends to get more extreme as physical
activity goes up so if you add a little
bit of physical activity
to your daily routine you will expect a
fairly considerable percentage of that
to actually
increase your total daily energy
expenditure but when you start to get to
really really high levels of daily
physical activity
there is a greater degree of energy
constraint so there is more compensation
happening such that when you start
adding more and more and more and more
physical activity the compensation gets
greater and greater so total daily
energy expenditure at a certain point
starts to get really constrained
that is
a model that opposes a different
conceptual model for energy expenditure
and that is the additive model the
additive model
is
strictly speaking
i think we can safely say it's not
fully correct right like we know that
energy compensation happens to some
extent in certain situations right
correct but but the additive model is
completely simplistic which is
i don't care how much physical activity
you do if you add 100 calories to your
day your total daily energy expenditure
is going to go up by 100 calories a day
like that that's pretty much the
additive model it's completely
simplistic it makes no accommodation for
energy compensation
so uh we've talked about energy
compensation before we've talked about
how
it clearly varies a lot between
individuals
uh people with high body fat uh tend to
have a greater degree of compensation
based on the observational literature
in most cases on average we only
compensate by about 28
which means about 72 percent of the
calories we add through exercise truly
are driving total daily energy
expenditure upward so that's kind of
where we left the conversation but what
willis and colleagues wanted to know is
when we compare
the additive model and the constrained
model
how do they look in different states of
energy balance so
does one model versus the other perform
better when a person is in negative
energy balance or caloric deficit
uh how do the two different models
compare when we look at energy balance
um so just you know people eating
approximately their maintenance calories
relatively weight stable and then how do
these models compare when we look at
positive energy balance so when we look
at individuals who are um you know in an
energy surplus and as a result of that
you know generally gaining weight so
this was an observational study
the sample included 584
free living
adults in the united states
energy expenditure was measured using
doubly labeled water which is a very
very nice way to do that in free living
subjects and physical activity was
measured using accelerometers
the way they defined energy balance
because this was observational
they looked at change in body weight
over this fairly long observation period
so
if an individual gained more than three
percent of their baseline body weight
that was taken as an indicator they were
in positive energy balance if someone
lost more than three percent that was
assumed to indicate that they were in
negative energy balance and if you were
between those thresholds plus or minus
three percent you were assumed to be
in neutral energy balance so the results
were
they could get very complicated if you
want to to dig into the the details in
the methodology but
in a nutshell the results were pretty
simple
uh for people who were in neutral or
positive energy balance
the additive model actually did just
fine now we know that it's not strictly
perfectly true because energy
compensation does happen to an extent
but when you're talking about neutral or
positive energy balance what this tells
us is the degree of compensation is not
particularly large the additive model
did just fine in modeling those outcomes
however
in negative energy balance the
constrained model did a much better job
describing the data than the additive
model
the reason that i think this is cool and
the reason i find it to be pretty
exciting and wanted to acknowledge it on
the on the show here
is because when you talk about the
constrained energy expenditure model
and who is
experiencing this constraint and to what
degree
sometimes people will point to findings
in the literature that seem to be a
little bit hard to understand right so
it you know one of the reasons that
people
um or one of the ways that people kind
of defend and promote
the constrained model is when we look at
two different societies so for example
poncer in a lot of his earlier research
they would look at total daily energy
expenditure
and they would look at it in a very
affluent society where there's a lot of
industrialization most jobs were quite
sedentary
and they would look at total daily
energy expenditure there and compare it
to societies where there has been less
industrialization and most of the day is
spent doing work that is physically
quite taxing so
you would assume
that of course the
more sedentary more industrialized
society would have lower total daily
energy expenditure but surprisingly they
were actually they tend to be quite
comparable when you compare across these
two uh group two different populations
or groups of individuals so
a lot of people would look at that and
and be a little bit confused about how
that is and then sometimes make the
interpretation well
apparently energy compensation is so
robust that no matter what you do total
daily energy expenditure is going to be
the same
but at the same time we look at other
scenarios where like if you look at
athletes and you compare the total daily
energy expenditure of an athlete versus
a more sedentary person within the same
population
that physical activity is driving total
daily energy expenditure upward yeah you
know there are these instances where you
have these discrepancies where sometimes
the additive model looks fine
sometimes the comp the compensation or
the um the constrained model looks fine
and
we never really knew how to sort through
some of these apparent discrepancies
uh another great example is like i've
mentioned this before i know a lot of
endurance athletes who eat like crazy
and train like crazy um but but clearly
their total daily energy expenditure is
quite high because they're eating a ton
of food and never gaining weight but i
also in the physique world have known
plenty of people who it seems like they
virtually live on a treadmill they are
chronically dieting
and you're like man those treadmill
hours do not seem to be moving the
needle like like you you look at this
individual and say
i think they really are eating fairly
low to moderate calorie intake and
spending a lot of time on the treadmill
and something about these numbers just
doesn't seem to line up yeah beyond like
oh i assume that they're just binging
and i don't know about it
so i think what's cool about
this um
explaining this variability within the
context of energy balance is that it
kind of helps us make sense of some of
these findings you know so
why do we see
[Music]
apparently a high level of energy
constraint in the chronic diet or on the
treadmill but it seems less extreme in
the endurance athlete i think a lot of
it has to do with fueling right so
endurance athletes
uh usually when you have good coaches in
charge of the team there's a high
priority and a big emphasis on fueling
for your training like it is explicitly
a goal to maintain neutral energy
balance and then when you see people
falling short of that very quickly you
see symptoms of relative energy
deficiency in sport like when that goes
off and
negative energy balance is maintained
for a while you start to see some of
those symptoms of
metabolic adaptation and relative energy
deficiency in sport
when you look at the other scenario
where someone is a chronic diet or doing
all that cardio it would make sense that
we see a more extreme example of energy
compensation there because they are
chronically trying to maintain that
neutral or that negative energy balance
whereas the endurance athlete is
hopefully making a focused effort to
maintain neutral or even slightly
positive energy balance and then when we
look at you know these
some of the earlier work by poncer for
example you look at an affluent
industrialized society one of the things
you tend to see is an increase in body
weight over time
generally speaking
in you know those types of populations
where there's a lot of sedentary work
and an excess of calories and an
obesogenic environment
most people are spending most of their
adult years
in many cases in a slight positive
energy surplus positive energy balance
on the flip side you could imagine that
in a less industrial society an
industrialized society
um where there's a lot of physical labor
on a daily basis it's probably a lot
less likely that you're spending that
much of your time in positive energy
balance and when you look at the the
different populations studied
within those studies themselves you can
see a huge mismatch in body fat
percentage despite similarities in total
daily energy expenditure so
i think that this is a really
fascinating um finding and i think it
definitely passes
that sanity check uh and and helps
contextualize some of these findings
where sometimes the additive model seems
to do well
and sometimes the constrained model
seems to do well and i think energy
balance is uh is a huge factor um
dictating which model makes sense in
which particular scenario so
um
i think this also has relevance um
you know working in the physique space
and doing a lot of nutrition and fitness
coaching over the years
you do run into some situations where
people are truly puzzled
um
you know they're they're trying to lose
weight but they're struggling to lose
weight and
they look around they see other people
who are
succeeding apparently quite easily with
their weight loss goals and this kind of
variation between people in the weight
loss process can be perplexing sometimes
but when you start digging into this
whole area of research
we should
really expect a tremendous amount of
variability
in the individual's
weight loss experience you know and what
i mean by that is
even if we ignore exercise we know
that total daily energy expenditure
varies a lot from person to person even
when they're the same body size
and even if they have the same amount of
fat free mass that was one of the key
findings in the paper
i believe poncer was the lead author of
that with the the doubly labeled water
study where they looked at total daily
energy expenditure we discussed it on
the podcast but even at the same level
of fat free mass there was a great deal
of variability in total daily energy
expenditure between people
we also know that energy compensation
does occur when we exercise but it
varies a lot in magnitude apparently
from person to person and depending on
now we seem to to see that it varies
based on the energy status of the
individual positive negative or neutral
energy balance we also know that
metabolic adaptation occurs when we
restrict energy uh but that also seems
to vary quite a bit from person to
person
so we've got this variability between
individuals to start with just based on
you know resting energy expenditure and
total daily energy expenditure but then
when you look at variability in terms of
energy compensation variability in terms
of metabolic adaptation and the way that
we
restrict non-exercise activity in
response to an energy deficit we start
with a lot of variability and then we
add more variability and then we add
more variability so
i think it's almost kind of reassuring
when you look into this research and you
say
why does it seem that responses vary so
much and then when you dig into it
you say well they kind of have to right
like
when we know all these sources of
variability how could they not uh and i
i know that can be frustrating when when
people
are pushing really hard toward a weight
loss goal and it seems a lot more
challenging when they compare to others
and compare to their peers but i also
think there's something reassuring about
that where it's not like this set of
goals is
inaccessible to you but what we have to
do is focus in on
what we know about this variability and
how we might put together some
strategies and solutions to alleviate uh
you know some of these increased
challenges that you're facing so
um one of the things this is going to be
a shameless plug which is not the
intention of the the segment
but i know that you've noticed this um
with macro factor we do keep a real-time
running estimate of your estimated total
daily energy expenditure and you've
mentioned in the road to the stage that
over time you can see that dropping yeah
um and
you know that that is calculated in a
deterministic fashion such that i mean
it is what it is
and if you could not see that and you
couldn't actually get a sense of that
data it would be immensely frustrating
to run into plateaus in your weight loss
but when you can see that at least you
can contextualize those plateaus you can
look at the data and say
oh
i'm reaching a plateau
my diet but dietary intakes have been
the same but clearly i can see that my
energy expenditure is dropping uh over
time so
um i think it's really nice to have that
actionable
feedback that you can observe and most
importantly
what these these studies tend to tell us
is even if you solve the equation and
you get a correct calorie intake and a
correct physical activity level to
support your goal rate of weight loss
that is a temporary solution because
these things will change as physical
activity changes and as energy
availability changes and as your body
weight changes so that's why it is
critically important to keep an eye on
these things because they are not static
they're dynamic in nature yeah for sure
and and just to be clear with that uh
with that brief macro factor plug
it's less that we pick segments of the
podcast for the purpose of uh promoting
macro factor and more that
you know there are these things that we
would be talking about anyways and and
these aspects of physiology that might
make it
uh
if not challenging at least like require
some some human effort to figure this
[ __ ] out for yourself to determine what
the the appropriate calorie level for
your goals is so it was just like hey
what if we made a diet app that did all
of this [ __ ] for you um
so yeah it's more that
um
you know we we created a product that
would
fill a need related to things that we
talk about anyways and now that the
products out it's not like we're going
to stop talking about those subjects
right and we also monitor related topics
to make sure that if there's a place to
improve the app that we're able to do
that right like
uh you know this is an area of research
that we're bound to follow intently
because if there's an opportunity to
optimize then we're gonna take that yeah
for sure um okay so uh just to wrap
things up there uh this is a body or an
area of the research that's evolved
really significantly over like the last
year to be honest which is it's exciting
to
i mean i've been writing about these
topics literally since like 2014
and
ah
kind of nothing happened between like
2014 and like 2019 well
yeah that's not entirely true well it's
not that nothing happened but the change
in the last couple years has been
exceptional yeah like the dramatic the
first big poncer paper that kind of
proposed the constrained energy model
that came out i believe in 2016. yes um
and i remember like i saw that when it
came out and i would just like share it
when people were talking about um
like hey you know i i'm trying to lose
weight and i'm exercising this much and
like
something doesn't tend to be working out
or it doesn't seem to be working out i'd
say like hey there's this researcher
herman poncer cool paper you should
check it out and so like i basically did
that from 2016 to like 2019
um
but by that point i think some people
are like slightly sketched out by that
reference because it's just like hey you
have this one paper that's proposing the
constrained uh energy expenditure model
why hasn't there been follow-up work on
this why aren't other groups getting
similar results i was like [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] have i been giving people bad
advice for for the last several years um
yeah and then in in 2019 the floodgates
kind of broke and and there's been a lot
more research in that area yeah but it's
been really cool because like i said i
mean i was aware of that uh the big mo
it was mostly a review paper by ponce it
might have had a little bit of original
data in there if i recall correctly but
i remember that paper in 2016 which kind
of distilled the main points of the idea
but i think a lot of people who were
more skeptically minded
looked at and said yeah there's not like
a
a lot of experimental evidence there's
not a lot of like really tightly
controlled evidence
um
and there were some of these scenarios
where you're like i don't know in this
case the additive model seems fine right
like because yeah sometimes people would
kind of over interpret the constrained
model and make conclusions that really
lacked face validity so
the uh
the 2016 paper laid the
foundation for the like you said the
floodgates have really opened the last
two years and a lot of these gaps in
knowledge have been filled so it's been
an exciting time for
for someone who's been following this
for
like eight years or so to see
uh a lot of these papers coming out and
you know one other thing i'll add is i
think one of the reasons we talk about
this so frequently is like now that
now that burn came out and the idea of
the
of the uh constrained energy model kind
of does have broader cultural purchase
within the evidence-based fitness sphere
um
i do see a lot of
very bad interpretations of it pretty
frequently like um
this is something where as a content
creator i see all the time with my work
like if i make a somewhat nuanced point
about 30
of the people are going to come away
with it
come away from that with a very
simplistic point that massively
oversimplifies what i was trying to say
and i think the same thing has happened
with the constrained
the constrained energy expenditure model
where i now see
quite a lot of people um
saying like oh yeah yeah you should
check out this guy poncer he has this
cool book burn did you know that
actually when you exercise that doesn't
change your total daily energy
expenditure at all uh it's fully
compensated for like your needs gonna go
down your metabolic rate's gonna go down
um so yeah actually the amount of
exercise you do bears no relation to how
many calories you burn in a day which uh
is wrong
right yeah but i i do see that uh that
interpretation floating around in the
ether pretty frequently so
yeah i mean it's it's it's a pretty
nuanced topic um
that is difficult to boil down to a
sound bite
but
the two
the two most sound biteable
interpretations are the additive model
very simplistic
or
what i would call like maximum
compensation uh that's also like a very
simplistic interpretation but both of
which are wrong um
so yeah i i think there's value in just
continuing to talk about the topic and
try to reiterate to people that it is a
a relatively nuanced subject
yeah
all right so moving on what do you have
next for us yeah so i i've got a little
research review as well um yeah i'll
start with that i also just have one
random thought that doesn't really fit
well into our
typical segment structure
but i'll save that for later
so anyway um
maybe
two months ago or so two or three months
ago um
i
mentioned on the podcast that a
new meta-analysis had been published on
concurrent training and the interference
effect
and that
the abstract of that meta-analysis
basically stated that the interference
effect is fake uh at least as far as it
as it uh relates to strength and
hypertrophy um and i mentioned at the
time like yeah like i haven't had an
opportunity to read it yet this is the
abstract i'll i'll probably dig into it
eventually
so just kind of to circle back on that i
did actually dig into that
i reviewed it for a research brief in
mass
and
yeah gonna talk about it a little bit
so uh it was a meta-analysis on
concurrent training and the interference
effect um
just as kind of background uh concurrent
training is
basically a training program that
simultaneously uh includes resistance
training and
aerobic cardio endurance type training
and the interference effect is the idea
that doing cardio can interfere with
adaptations that are typically
associated with resistance training so
hypertrophy strength development uh
velocity and power development
etc uh it is worth noting that
um sometimes i see
the interpretation that the interference
effect is the idea that both strength
training and cardio training interfere
with each other um but it's basically
just a one directional thing like cardio
might interfere with strength related
developments uh the opposite is not true
for strength training interfering with
cardio uh related adaptations
just a just a quick note to throw in
there but anyway
as it relates to
strength and hypertrophy and power
development
this meta-analysis was was interested in
that
that topic and so the authors searched
or the author started with a systematic
literature search uh for all studies
that met four inclusion criteria first
needed to be a longitudinal study that
lasted at least four weeks
second the groups needed to
so there needed to be at least one
resistance training only group and at
least one concurrent training group
doing both resistance training and some
some form of endurance training uh and
both groups needed to have the exact
same resistance training stimulus so
you know if if one group was training
three times per week with a particular
program like if the resistance training
group was training three times per week
with a particular program the concurrent
training group also needed to be doing
the exact same resistance training
program three times per week with cardio
added on top of it so for example if a
study compared two days of lifting ver
four days of lifting versus two days of
lifting in two days of cardio that would
not have met these inclusion criteria
uh the study needed to include
measurements of maximal strength
explosive strength and or muscle
hypertrophy
and lastly for
measures of for for strength measures or
power slash explosive strength measures
the
the outcomes assessed needed to be
exercises that were trained in the
actual study so for example
if you're interested in lower body
strength development and you have a
program where people are doing squats
then you can test squat 1rm that that
would count for inclusion in this study
but if you had people training squats
and leg press and the only strength
measure you had
was
like maximum isometric knee extension
torque that would not have met uh the
inclusion criteria so they they rounded
up all of the studies that did meet
those criteria and there were 43 studies
with a grand total of
1090 subjects that did meet those
inclusion criteria
37 of the studies had strength measures
18 of them had measures of power or
explosive strength and 15 of the studies
assessed hypertrophy
um
and in short they did find that there
wasn't
um
that there wasn't a
significant mean effect
um
kind of in favor of concurrent training
mitigating strength development or
hypertrophy um and not not is and it
wasn't even one of those situations
where it's like ah you know there's
there's a pretty notable effect in one
direction but there's some variability
in study results and so kind of the 95
confidence interval barely crosses zero
p equals 0.07 or something like that
like no there was no difference for
uh strength development the standardized
mean difference uh like the effect size
basically was uh
0.06 p value 0.45
and for hypertrophy the standardized
mean difference was 0.01
p value 0.92 which is
as close as you can get to no difference
in a meta-analysis basically um
and uh however for
like vertical jump height measures of
explosive strength and power uh there
was a significant effect uh in favor of
concurrent training mitigating those
types of adaptations so you know if
you're
interested in
improving your one rep max squat or if
you're interested in
adding muscle to your frame it seems
like you can do concurrent training
probably and not really need to worry
about it too much like
the meme of cardio kills your gains
seems to mostly be incorrect in those
contexts however if you're trying to
improve your vertical jump uh maybe even
improve like your power cleaner snatch
snatch
improve your
i don't know 100 meter sprint time
something like that then concurrent
training might not be quite as
beneficial like doing a fair bit of
endurance training probably is going to
negatively affect those power related
adaptations
so it's worth noting
that a
literal and fully expansive
interpretation of these results is
probably unjustified so for example
you probably aren't going to be able to
train
effectively for
a power lifting world championship and a
like hundred mile ultra marathon
simultaneously
as with any
scientific pursuit it's important to
interpret the results
within the
constraints of the actual variables
being studied and so for most concurrent
training studies the cardio stimulus is
like
you know maybe two to four times per
week for 20 to 45 minutes per session
and within that context like for that
given dose of
cardio it doesn't seem like you really
need to worry about the interference
effect um however if you were doing way
way more cardio than that then like yeah
it's it's probably going to have a
negative impact on strength development
and hypertrophy
and also it's worth keeping in mind the
resistance training stimulus in studies
like this it's pretty similar you know
people are lifting two to four times per
week uh
you know three to four exercises per
muscle group for a few sets like you
know people aren't training as if
they're prepping for the olympia
so if your
resistance training volume is way higher
and you're really really pushing your
capacity to recover uh just with
resistance training in the gym then
there might then there might be some
interference effect even from relatively
moderate doses of endurance training
so you know it's it's worth keeping that
in mind however i i do think that this
meta-analysis
shifts kind of my mental
it shifts my priors when it comes to
uh concurrent training and the
interference effect my
my mental framework essentially used to
be
that under most contexts the inter the
interference effect was
uh was real relevant and of a reasonable
magnitude where it was essentially your
job to try to figure out the perfect mix
of variables to
mitigate this thing that was likely to
happen to the greatest extent possible
and now kind of my prior is under most
circumstances you probably don't need to
worry about it too much and probably you
don't need to go super far out of your
way to attempt to mitigate it however
there probably are contexts where you do
need to do that so if you're pushing or
training really really hard or if you
want to do a lot of endurance training
or you know
situations like that then you probably
do need to worry about it a little bit
but if you're just kind of doing
what most people would consider a normal
dose of resistance training and you're
on a relatively normal
cardio program you know you're not
training to be an endurance athlete you
just want to get out and run two or
three miles three four days per week in
a in a situation like that you probably
don't need to worry about the the
interference effect uh with concurrent
training to any notable degree uh and
and the last thing that i'll add is
if you are still concerned about it and
there's one thing that you want to do
that's going to matter more than
anything else
or mitigating the interference effect
it's just separating training sessions
uh when it's possible so
you know if you want to both go for a
run and get a lift in on a single day if
you can split that into two sessions
separated by at least four to six hours
uh you'll get a lot of mileage out of
that
and if possible just do it on separate
days um
so yeah that's that's the state of of
the literature as it is now it's not
that the interference effect cannot
occur it's just that under most normal
circumstances it probably doesn't occur
for most people most of the time
yeah i mean an extreme case of this um
i've gotten several questions in the
past where people are like
you know they're really into lifting and
they want to maximize their strength and
hypertrophy but they're like man eric i
don't know what to do like i walk to
class every day and it's like
it's like a 25 minute walk or they'll
say like i ride my bike to work so i'm
on my bike uh 35 minutes a day and so i
i think the research
i'm quite confident that the research is
increasingly alleviating those types of
concerns but yeah you know i think you
did a great job summarizing the study
and i think it's great that all these
nerds and lab coats are keeping
themselves busy but
have you ever seen the memes that
compare the quads of elite marathon
runners to elite strength athletes
i i have seen them
do you have any i mean it seems like
there's kind of conflicting evidence in
that regard i i don't think that
warrants her response uh however i i do
have a couple things to add one is uh
whenever i talk about any sort of study
i generally shout out the title just for
people who don't want to check the show
notes but they
want to listen and type it in i guess
the title of this meta-analysis if you
want to check it out for yourself is
compatibility of concurrent aerobic and
strength training for skeletal muscle
size and function
an updated systematic review and
meta-analysis by schumann
um
second uh
based on what you just said like you
know like hey i just walked to class do
i need to be worried about that um
unfortunately
i think that one of my favorite
bodybuilders ever tom platts is
responsible for
some of some of that type of thinking so
like that was actually like a brain worm
that that made it into my head at one
point because dude platts had if you're
listening to this and you don't know who
tom platts is and you care about
physical culture at all just google tom
platts p-l-a-t-z
he had some of the freakiest legs ever
and he was also competing before
kind of the mass monster era when
bodybuilders
really figured out peptide hormones just
right to get [ __ ] huge so like he was
competing prior to that era but he still
had legs that would
not be out of place on the olympia stage
today probably freakier than half of the
current olympia competitors and if
you're going to look him up look up
first of all pictures yes but also
there's a classic video
of him squatting
it was like 500 for 23. right yeah it
was like over 20 reps with at least 500
pounds it is
a fascinating video it's incredible yeah
definitely watch it but anyway so tom
platts incredible set of wheels awesome
bodybuilder uh but
he had this quote that i came across
when my mind was still much younger and
squishier and more impressionable
where he said uh don't run if you can
walk don't walk if you can sit and don't
sit if you can lay down just just
emphasizing the importance of rest for
uh
really making sure that you could train
your legs as hard as possible um and so
yeah like i
like for a while there i found that very
influential it's like dude if tom says
it like it's got to be legit um
and so you know maybe when maybe if you
have leg development that rivals tom
platts who knows you might be in a
situation where you need to be so
concerned about the interference effect
that you shouldn't run if you can walk
you shouldn't walk if you can sit and
you shouldn't sit if you can lay down
but if you are not
if you don't have quads that are in the
same zip code as tom platts you probably
don't need to worry about it all that
much
and just based on the
general concept of how probabilities
work if you're listening to this show
you probably are not rivaling tom platts
correct
and that's not an insult that is
a testament to the
once-in-a-generation leg development
that tom platt's had yeah that's that's
a
completely quantitative statement yeah
yeah all right so i was going to talk a
little bit about body
recomposition but i think i'm actually
going to save that i think a great way
to uh to wrap things up here i'm curious
about your
miscellaneous thought that doesn't
conform to our typical show segments i'm
curious what this is about i mean i
assume this is a miscellaneous thought
you've had as well
um and it's something that we've
indirectly referenced on the podcast
before and that is just the idea that
when it comes to supplementation
sometimes i wonder if we are
maybe selling certain supplements short
or if there are some supplements that
may be effective that we currently
believe to be ineffective
simply based on the fact that
most of the supplements that people take
there's not great dose response research
on them where so here here's how most
here's how most supplement
bodies of research develop
someone does a study they test a
particular dose of a particular
supplement and it works and then other
people say like oh cool supplement
worked for that
let's either try to replicate those
findings or test them for a different
activity or in a different population
and then hey what dose are we going to
use oh well this dose worked in this
study let's just use that dose and
basically it just snowballs from there
where when an efficacious dose is found
either that dose or something very very
similar to it is used
in like 90 of the literature um
and so like there are some exceptions so
there's a lot of fish oil research and
there's a fair bit of dose response
research on fish oil uh caffeine is
studied a lot there's a lot of dose
response research on caffeine which
tells us you probably don't want to take
11 milligrams per kilogram correct yeah
um so yeah so yeah there are some
notable exceptions where
um some studies have a fair bit of of
dose response research on them but most
of them don't um and where this has come
up on the podcast previously
is uh i think you talked about this beta
alanine
i can't recall if it came up on the
podcast but i'm certain it came up in a
mass article and in the mass audio round
tables but
yeah that was the first thing i thought
of when you started mentioning well i
thought yeah that was one of the two
things i thought of but yeah there was a
really fast and fascinating meta
analysis like
one or two years ago
where they uh did some some really
sophisticated statistical analysis and
their results basically indicated
that most of the beta alanine research
we've seen to date
is probably not saturating muscle
carnosine levels to a maximal extent or
even a near maximal extent
um and so like my title for the mass
article was like
is every beta alan beta alanine study
under dosed yeah um because uh the
analysis would indicate that most of
what we know about beta alanine is from
study designs that probably came nowhere
near close to maximizing our potential
to actually
saturate muscle carnosine storage via
beta alanine supplementation so it'd be
like if we uh started out the body of
literature with like one gram a day of
creatine and never tried five and just
said ah this doesn't really seem to do a
whole lot um because yeah one gram a day
is not going to saturate muscle creatine
so
it was i was really stoked about that
meta-analysis because i had actually
bumped into roger harris at a conference
quite a few years before
and roger harris is like the godfather
of beta alanine like he most people
would credit him for pretty much
everything that came after unless i'm
mistaken but uh but yeah he was saying
this several years ago he's like ah man
we gotta start pushing it um but but
yeah so that that's definitely
one of the first things that came to
mind yeah so uh yeah so who knows like
beta alanine is currently sitting in a
place in the literature
where like uh you know maybe it's
effective for improving endurance
performance for kind of like middle
distances but uh you know if it does
affect strength endurance in the gym
maybe it's only like two or three
percent or something like that like does
it
maybe it has a small effect but it
doesn't seem to have a particularly
notable effect based on the studies that
currently exist but you know if the
studies that currently exist are
under-dosing beta-alanine by a factor of
two or three who knows it could be
considerably more effective and we just
don't know it yet um another
another supplement that i know we've
talked about this on the podcast is
betaine um
where like human studies use mostly the
same dosage but there's some animal
research particularly in pigs
where like they just use it as an
additive in livestock feed and it seems
to help quite a bit with lean mass
accretion and also
uh reductions in fat mass where you know
maybe an
equivalent dose in humans would be
similarly effective but at this point
hard to know just hasn't been tested um
and
what what brought this to mind is
another example came up in the stronger
by science facebook group earlier this
week
the the topic of capsaicin and potential
ergogenic effects of capsaicin
supplementation came up um
and
like basically there have been some
studies in rodents suggesting that it
can
quite
robustly increase
endurance so
not a particularly pretty experimental
model they basically just give rats or
mice supplements put them in the water
uh and just
you know let them tread water until they
sink um
and so
for mice i think i think it was 10
milligrams per kilogram of capsaicin uh
seemed to be quite effective
for
improving endurance in that context like
quite a bit more effective than
capsaicin seems to be in human research
you kind of do the math so you have to
convert a rodent dose to a human
equivalent dose
because basically as
as things get larger the relative dose
to have a similar physiological effect
is is lower um but but basically in
humans uh you you take a roden dose you
divide it by about 12 12.3 and that's
the human equivalent dose and that works
out to like 50 to 80 milligrams of
capsaicin as a supplement or
kind of the the normal range of human
body masses um which is like two to
three times higher than the capsaicin
doses that that have ever been studied
in humans so like that that just kind of
got the wheels turning like you know who
knows capsaicin may be more effective
than than we're currently giving it
credit for uh beta alanine may be quite
a bit more effective than what we're
currently giving it credit for
um betaine might be quite a bit more
effective than what we're currently
giving it credit for and so it's
it is it is interesting because uh like
like i mentioned with um
with concurrent training like ultimately
it's hard to interpret a body of
research
outside of the bounds of the details
that have actually been studied so you
know
you're not looking at concurrent
training research of someone prepping
for a marathon in the olympia at the
same time so you can't generalize that
far
in much the same way with supplement
research like we can look and say like
hey this supplement at this dosage
doesn't seem to be particularly
effective but without a fair bit of dose
response research
that doesn't necessarily mean that it's
time to write a supplement off uh quite
yet so
you know i don't know
uh
necessarily what to do with this
information because one of the
like i
i personally like i'm not planning on
going out and buying a ton of
supplements and super dosing them and
seeing what happens because i'm
my just natural inclination towards
supplementation is pretty conservative
um and one of the knock-on effects of
not having dose-response research when
it comes to performance outcomes for a
particular supplement you also don't
have dose response research when it
comes to adverse effects of a particular
supplement so um
you know like a two to three times
higher dose of capsaicin
could be who knows could be very
effective for
uh you know ergogenic purposes in humans
might improve exercise performance quite
a bit but then who knows if you've ever
had a lot of spicy food
maybe you're the type of person where
spicy food really messes with your
stomach or maybe
what happens the next day is just so
unpleasant that you don't want to you
don't you don't want to worry about
supplementing with it um
so yeah like like uh adverse event
reports you know they also exist within
the range of doses that have actually
been tested so
um yeah i wouldn't necessarily recommend
someone just going on pubmed finding
every supplement that has been reported
to not work and then just say to
yourself like what if i took five times
as much like would it work then um
so just kind of like theoretically who
knows maybe it would um but i i
personally don't want to be the guinea
pig for that uh but it it does just make
me wonder um
just based on the fact that
they're like i i do so i kind of think
that once
if i ran science and it was just a
completely top-down thing and i was the
god of it um
one that would be
terrible that would be horrifying but
one change i would make to supplement
research practices
is the first time you get a study coming
out saying like hey this supplement
seems to be effective
the second study that someone would need
to do
is a pretty robust dose response study
on it just just to see
if that dosage used in the first study
was the optimal dose for that supplement
as it stands now for the vast majority
of supplements in the literature those
studies just don't exist and so
when it comes to optimal dose dosing
even for supplements we know to be
effective um we're kind of flying blind
which
you know could be better
yeah i mean a lot of times
rather than taking your approach where
the second study is dose response
across a broad range of dosages
usually what happens is that one study
comes out and then we say okay let's do
20 more studies using outcomes that are
measured with
kind of questionable reliability in a
variety of slightly distinct populations
and then
in like six years we can do a
meta-analysis and it might tell us that
the effect size is worthwhile and then
four years later you replicate the first
study in the body of literature but in
women that's yes it's always
republication um
well yeah because no one bothers to
study women in the first 30 tries right
which is ridiculous but yeah yeah um but
no i
see you mentioned that you tend to be
conservative with regards to
supplementation
and i honestly don't know where i fall
in that spectrum because
thinking back like i think of myself as
being on the conservative side and
fairly skeptical but i do write about
supplements a lot and i field a lot of
questions about supplements and
sometimes people get annoyed that i
leave the door cracked open you know i
think right now with supplements there's
these kind of
polar opposites where there are some
people who take like 31 supplements the
moment they get out of bed right and
some of them have no evidence whatsoever
yeah the other side of the spectrum is
like if if the first three studies don't
all have an effect size of at least like
point three they're like uh that's a
joke and anyone who leaves the door open
is a charlatan
so like yeah i mean i've i've written
about these topics before and i've said
like it's possible that most of what we
know about beta alanine underestimates
the true effects or the
what it is capable of in terms of the
true effect size
i've also mentioned with betaine pretty
much everybody studies 2.5 grams a day
um
i can think of
one study that did like 9.9 ish but i
don't think they did any lifting with it
so
uh yeah i mean the the animal research
would suggest that that's nowhere near
enough um and then the same thing goes
with capsaicin as you as you reviewed
but
i'm also really torn on this topic
because
i usually end those articles by saying
yeah don't try this but someone should
you know like and what i mean by that is
we need researchers to look into these
dose response effects specifically with
regards to safety but to do it in a
controlled safe environment which is
what research should afford you you
should be able to carefully monitor the
trial and terminate quickly if there are
severe adverse events or just an
unacceptably high prevalence of mild
adverse events yeah um but yeah i've
been in a tight spot where people have
reached out to me and been like hey eric
check out this dose i'm gonna try what
do you think and i'm like dude i can't
sign off on that because
i don't know if that's safe you know but
uh but yeah it's a really tricky
situation when you try to get down to it
and with these specific ingredients
what's really tough is
it's nice to say oh higher doses might
be better but there are logistical
challenges or at least some red flags
that i think are slowing down some of
that progress or that that
enthusiasm about studying higher and
higher doses so for capsaicin capsaicin
from my perspective is probably a no-go
but
higher doses might be more feasible with
capsi8 which is a non-pungent version of
capsaicin which should alleviate some of
the gi discomfort that you alluded to so
maybe that problem i think those doses
of capsaicin that i mentioned are
completely feasible uh okay but
anyway
uh
maybe if you don't have as robust a
stomach i think capsi8 is pop possibly a
solution to that you know but you look
at beta alanine you say oh let's go
higher with dosing the issue is if you
get over like two grams of serving
for most people that's going to be
enough to have a fairly uncomfortable
level of paresthesia that tingling
feeling that you get in your skin like
your face the back your hands
so um that's a logistical challenge and
people are talking about different time
release doses but with beta alanine it's
like until they put together really good
formulations for time release um beta
alanine supplements
you're either stuck with tingling like
crazy
or you're just supplementing all day
long because you're dividing it into you
know doses that are like one or two
grams each but you're trying to achieve
well over six grams a day so you feel
like you're just kind of constantly
taking the next dose all throughout the
day so logistically that's a challenge
and then when it comes to betaine i
believe
i'm not certain about this but i believe
i've seen some evidence
suggesting that there could be some
unfavorable effects on blood lipids when
the dose starts to get relatively high
and so that's something that they'll
have to sort out i think i've only seen
that in one study so could it be a false
positive could it be just an instance of
sampling error sure that that could be a
possibility but for each of these there
are so many unknowns about what happens
when you escalate the dose and i'm
hoping that some
intrepid researcher might hear this and
say hey that looks like a series of
three studies that would be
very feasible to do and very informative
so
yeah like i said i don't know where
people see me on the supplement spectrum
i'm i'm certain that no one cares to
place me on that spectrum but i know
i've taken flack for being too
conservative i've taken flack for being
too
open to supplementation so
personally i don't do
really much experimentation at all but i
do hope that this research develops uh
in the years that follow
all right so
moving on uh to play us out
as you alluded to greg last night was
the super bowl and we enjoyed it
together
we had some delicious bow buns that you
made which were phenomenal with some
mushroom in there and some fried rice
that you made that was terrific
with a variety of different tofu options
[Music]
now
i think we should close the show with
some reflections on the super bowl and
the nfl season my first thought when i
thought of this idea was certainly no
one cares
however
i looked into this and this is a
baffling stat
there's a list put together by nielsen
that's the company in the united states
that does like television ratings
so advertisers always look at the
nielsen data to decide how much they're
willing to pay for certain advertising
spots so if you look at the list made by
nielsen
of the all-time most watched single
network television broadcasts in united
states history by average viewership
uh the list of the top 30 of all time 28
of them are super bowls which i think is
absolutely baffling the only two on that
top 30 list were from 1983 and 1978 i
think there was a boxing match and the
finale of a mash if if i'm not mistaken
you know what
you're uh your data is already out of
date
what yeah um
i looked this up like three days ago
yeah i'm aware apparently the uh the
most recent super bowl just bumped the
boxing match and so so we're 29 a 30
yeah so now it's mash and 29 super bowls
so anyway i was like no one wants to
hear about this but apparently
it's like the only thing that people
tune into so what did you think about
the super bowl
uh
i
i wanted the bengals to win uh however
i i am glad that aaron donald finally
got a super bowl um i think that he's
one of the best defensive players in the
history of the league uh so that was
good to see
also i
just purely
from a
sadistic perspective i enjoy the pain
and suffering of detroit lions fans and
seen matt stafford play very good
football for so long in detroit and just
have such a bad team around him
consistently that
just zero playoff success to see him go
in a super bowl with another team his
first season after leaving detroit
incredible that's that's awesome like
just the fact that they as an organ this
is
detroit's just catching strays now even
though they weren't even in the game uh
but yeah the fact that the lions had
probably the best running back in nfl
history and barry sanders had no success
with him had
i think arguably not the greatest
receiver the greatest of course is jerry
rice but maybe the best receiver just in
terms of all of his physical skills and
calvin johnson and it's just such a
miserable organization that both of them
just retired in their prime rather than
continue playing for detroit
and then you have a very good
quarterback and you can't win with him
forever and then goes to another team
and wins the super bowl the first year
like even though i did want cincinnati
to win those two things both aaron
donald get in his super bowl and uh matt
matt stafford super bowl hopefully
causing pain and anguish for detroit
lions fans both of those two things do
do make the la win worth it to me that
is an interesting um
it's an interesting
glance at
how catastrophic a dysfunctional
organization can be because like like
you said i mean the talent
over the past several decades has been
phenomenal when you look at barry
sanders calvin johnson stafford it's not
just that he couldn't win the big game
with detroit they were never even like
remotely relevant that i can remember
they might have had one or two decent
seasons but i mean there's no way his
career record there's over 500 yeah i
think they went i think they went like
11 and five
couple seasons during his tenure but no
they were never like
upper echelon right so yeah
organizations when they're dysfunctional
they can
really shrink talent which is quite a
cautionary tale uh my perspective on the
super bowl i was rooting for cincinnati
most of my friends are you know because
i grew up in southern ohio
most of my friends are bengals fans my
brother is a huge bengals fan so
on their behalf i was rooting for the
bengals so i was kind of bummed out that
they kind of get the win but nonetheless
you know that was a good production the
the nfl playoffs when they started i
looked at the bracket
and i said this doesn't make any sense
because like if you looked at the
bracket and how the team shake out i was
like
there are going to be a lot of close
games early in the playoffs you know
normally you you give the the better
teams a nice easy path to you know to
the later rounds
and it just didn't turn out that way
looking at the bracket even before the
playoffs happened and so i was like this
is dumb the nfl's playing this wrong
uh
i'm eating my words with that because
like every game in the playoffs was
extremely close there were overtime
games like
you know no one really won by more than
like three points throughout the entire
playoffs so
while i didn't think it made sense from
a bracket building perspective it made
for some really compelling football at
every round yeah like top to bottom i
think this may have been just the
greatest slate of nfl playoff games ever
yeah but my fear is that the way they
put the bracket together it
it kind of
reduces the advantage that you get from
being a higher seed like you get the buy
which is a good thing wait what
didn't they put the bracket together the
same way they always put the bracket
together i don't know i didn't pay
attention until this year
[Laughter]
i just looked at the bracket i said this
looks weird there's gonna be a lot of
close games early and i thought that
would lead to some blowouts later in the
playoffs yeah but i was completely wrong
it was really compelling start to finish
no they i'm pretty sure the bracket's
the same as it's always been this was
just a year where there weren't any
like truly great teams like there was a
fair bit of parody
top to bottom for all of the teams that
made the playoffs but no it's it's two
wild card games uh and then one and two
get buys and then
uh number one seed plays kind of the
wild card game corresponding with the
worst of the team so one gets an easy
path and then
two seed that got the bye plays like the
more challenging of of the two wild card
winners and then
you know championship or conference
championship game super bowl i mean it
this was just a year with a lot of
parody yeah like it was the same system
as always i think well either way it
turned out to be very entertaining i was
hoping the bengals would pull it out but
uh you know the rams had a great year
and they played a great game so
congrats to them that's true um all
right so i think that does it for this
episode i didn't get to my segment on
body recomposition but that's kind of
the cliffhanger if you come back next
week i'm going to talk all about
body recomposition which is
simultaneously
trying to lose fat and gain muscle
it's an at a really active area in the
fitness space right now a lot of people
have conflicting opinions about how
feasible it is for different people
depending on their training history
their training status their body fat
level things like that so i'm going to
get into how feasible it is as a goal
and then beyond that how i would
actually structure a diet
a dietary approach to successfully
achieving body recomposition so that'll
be coming next next episode which is
exactly one week from today
but that is it for now so as always
thank you for joining us and we'll see
you in a week
thank you for listening to the stronger
buy science podcast
if you enjoyed the podcast be sure to
sign up for our free newsletter to get
concise breakdowns of relevant research
as well as 28 free training programs for
all skill levels and all schedules
we hate spam just as much as you do so
we'll only email you when we have
something really interesting to share
with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter or just go to the stronger by
science homepage and click the free
programs button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional
once again thank you for listening and
we will be back soon with another
episode of the stronger by science
podcast
[Music]
[Music]
you